[Laughter]
so yes please - bacon samplers please
[Music]
94 dickerson yeah you know anything
about house which is fine or do you
think pop and force better okay cool
okay thank you so much I mean there's so
much old wine that's like like this 94
Ravenswood then Dickerson was like a
wine I remember selling when I was like
a kid you know like I was like this is
gonna be really good wine one day let's
find out if I was right hey guys so
these couple of blogs are gonna be a
little bit different a little a little
more vague because we're working on a
very secret project that I'm super
excited about I mean look at look at
rowdy space look out look out look out
look out look how secret this is but as
you can imagine you've seen some of the
photos on Instagram put that up I think
it's gonna be a very big deal I think
you'll be super excited about it
I can't wait to announce it to all of
you and so these up these two episodes I
think are gonna really stand out as as a
little different side of me and my life
and the world I play in and I think
we're challenging ourselves to show a
little bit more of that where we're so
focused on giving value and it's really
about either a motivational mindset or
or a tactic or giving you an insight
into what I'm doing I've been seeing a
lot more of you tweeting things like you
know watch what Gary's doing whether
it's a Monday to Monday play lesser
things that don't be scared clay get in
here you can fix the meet while I'm
ranting I'm almost done it's all about
you you you do me
I'll do this and so that's what this
these two episodes are about and I hope
you enjoy them and I think value in the
vlog can come in the form that 99% of
the vlogs on YouTube have which is just
entertainment and escapism and
lightweight just getting to know people
and hopefully you know probably
hopefully d-roc and Bob Evan can do the
job editing these episodes
show you a little bit of those angles
that I don't think we should we I think
we agree we don't show enough up I'm Way
more funny than you guys post that at me
in one more time be funny right that it
you know what that's an interesting
insight be rock Colin write an article
le Monday morning a lot of you checked
out and enjoying Presidents Day about me
I'm up to some secret
they've given to you as a season ticket
holder so what could I do
I don't have small kids anymore nobody
wanted them you hate the Warriors I just
like the Knicks how much fun I'm just a
very big investor into like I always
play for the long haul so early on
most of my companies make no money and
in one meeting I was like look you know
understand we're making goose egg
nothing
Zera he lost it was a very formal
meeting with like billion-dollar
executives and ties I'm like [ __ ]
goose egg I was into it my summers and
that wasn't too bad it feels so weird to
have a lot of time I was antsy in the
meeting you're gonna have so much fun
with that story about Expo like in three
minutes you explain here two minutes
explaining how [ __ ] up the wine
business is you imagine that when that
clip plays in 40 years when this whole
cycle goes down I'll enjoy that so much
so many people don't understand what you
were saying that's my life neva from
prohibition in 1930 it's caused yep
dysfunctional liquor and alcohol
business in this country yep what what
time's our meeting well 3:30 so we're
we're we're supposed to be there now so
let's get there how far away we 10
minutes about eight minutes
yeah no coffee
if there's an archery store we'll stop
by other than that didn't see it last so
we set it to get a beer hey man Gary
Gary how are you yeah Nathan ornate
whatever you want to call me they're
trying to make theirs running a business
here John that's back to my thesis which
is we're talking about Merlot we're
talking about the right bank of Bordeaux
this is historic this is high-quality
wine one [ __ ] movie there's in two
two and just to really write what up
yeah
that's when you came in that's good man
that's early the rock just texted me
guys we'll get coffee when obviously
we're gonna pop it I'll buy it right
when ami when ami has a Burger King on
his side
is he a Burger King guy no guys
Bennett retailer and realtor's was the
reasons he's digging now we're seeing
here we go
want coffee but I want it from something
that's on our side that doesn't veer off
I don't like the u-turn play and if we
don't have anything we don't have
anything if he dies he dies Starbucks
there is what you gotta make it
something we got to make a right no it's
a huge shopping center no I feel like
I'm you missed it let's keep going look
I think the biggest thing first of all
I'm glad we were able to make this
happen
I'm glad you texted me to Victor and
it's good to see you brother
I miss you class listen the opportunity
you know the the biggest strength of the
biggest weakness is the same thing for
you guys which is all of this is so
native and normal to you old guys like
Victor and I we realize how [ __ ]
crazy this opportunity is the the fact
that it doesn't cost anything to get out
there just time and having talent in a
certain genre so the biggest thing I can
tell you is please don't underestimate
how special this time is the Internet is
now at scale but it's still early and
eventually it's gonna get harder and
harder and harder once everybody
understands this truth and so what I'm
doing is I'm going hard right it's
Instagram its YouTube its podcasting I'm
just going all in because I realize this
is a moment in time the same way that
Google AdWords or a moment in time for
my dad's liquor store and how I grew
that business so I would say my biggest
my biggest thing is hey please take
advantage of this right like like the
days of building a million followers on
Instagram Organic is are going to go
away
and it's gonna get harder and the fact
that a lot of this comes natural to you
you know obviously you're taking this
class you're thinking about your world
but if you've got a passion around a
subject matter and you think you have
something to say go hard don't worry
about what other people think
nothing just we were in town and we have
the night and just emailed some people
we are fond of and here we are those
people couldn't make it
[Laughter]
we panicked and just send some R in Lee
said the bulk email you guys replied
like I wouldn't even call them
comparable so I just think it's the way
we we take a lot of things from
Hollywood and other things that nature
but the advances we've made no no no
it's amazing how many people believe it
no I have I just one guy tweeting me and
a half bottle made in Trouty I'm sure
you're willing to let that go you might
want to just pound it
before you go to sleep I threw up all
over my face you to you to you to you -
yeah I mean all these guys know each
other yeah they found each other
let me have some fun with this right
yeah John Deere John Deere I go John
Deere [ __ ] Joe here because that's
the green like the Jess that's um
[Music]
guys you don't understand
you'll love this clay my high school
years like my dad moved to a 28 acre
farm in hundred-and County New Jersey
like this is this is like the city
compared to where I grew up in my high
school years yeah so you know Jersey's
funny like there's pockets of Jersey
that are super rural I grew up in Iowa
not I even always in Jersey and even I
live in Manhattan like this is like
normal [ __ ] for me like our cow was like
my pet you know I'm getting dead [ __ ]
serious
[Music]
what's that we need to adjourn oh I saw
the Wrangler
guys you see that renovation you see
that renovation that's gonna be a mutiny
you're gonna walk into the booth
really I'm coming up clay clay I'm
coming up I want to see the boot room
show me the boot room they really are
huh why are they so expensive because
there's like crocodile or something what
is this what is it looking for boots you
like wearing boots huh I think I seen
these things for like 3 bucks at garage
sales incredible Yamini jet jerseys
mm-hmm yeah I'm pretty sure I'm not
gonna make this drop here I'm not gonna
do this I'm not gonna make this
placement so if I have no fear
everything else is a bonus I totally
agree with you yeah everybody goes in I
don't really want this I totally
different way farming in a different way
of thinking me too yeah I focus on the
negatives me to fix the negatives me to
[ __ ] do you want to manage the
positive me too no I'm gonna fix it 15
[ __ ] thing it's all I do for brother
that's right totally totally spend my
time I'm a [ __ ] do you know I say I'm a
firefighter when I go into when I write
occupation when I come back into America
I write I put fire yeah daughter walks
in she goes
fires that's what I do everybody know
uh-huh I don't worry about good have no
time and smell roses putting out fires
all right thank you
well no but I'm always working all right
so like I kiss on the cheek and she
bites my face off I'm always worried
yeah I think it's gonna be sunny
tomorrow what's the Vayner it'd be a
great SNL skit Dana Dan like no matter
what you say just hugs the data on the
spot and if you don't have it through
the last 30 years I think the best thing
we can do I mean I think we're having a
tactical discussion in the short term
and I'm thrilled and III think I'm head
I'm head nodding on a lot of this stuff
but I don't want to deviate from the
thing that I think is the most powerful
and I'd love to get people's thoughts
which is we need to ammo and flood
fifteen to twenty five-year-olds in the
channels that they consume with messages
like
some sort of rallying cry that gives
them the ammo because they're the new
energy and they they I absolutely
believe the drunk-driving smoking thing
that was brought up 15 minutes ago was
the most important insight because it
wasn't the establishment or the people
that were in it
it was the people underneath that
changed the movement our greatest mo is
persuading and informing but I think
selling to the unsellable is a wrong
play and I think on both sides of this
we are too numb and normalized and I
think this seed of 18 year olds and 16
year olds being pissed off and having
ammo just like them starting the biggest
companies in the world is exactly where
we should go with a bunch of different
messages and let them grab on to
something and go and I think that they
can absolutely affect the outcome it's
really rad founder used for the spine
[Music]
bang before people realize they like it
same old thing
[Music]
you
you